[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
m
mais
on l'appelle la fiesta del dulce nombre
et des réseaus la fête du doux nom de
jésus
elle se déroule chaque année dans les
faubourgs de synth et l'hérault nord de
la colombie 7000 spectateurs dans les
gradins un bon millier d'acteurs
amateurs dans l'arène
ici on dit que ces jeux avec les
taureaux existe depuis quatre siècles
bien avant que la corrida l'espagnol ait
pris les formes que nous lui connaissons
c'est notre tradition ici la vie n'a pas
de prix ce qui compte c'est le spectacle
et la coutume or
dans cette arène chaque année il ya des
morts les taureaux en sortent toujours
vivant
dans cette arène ils sont une
quarantaine à venir gagner de quoi vivre
il touche un salaire des éleveurs
auxquels s'ajoutent des primes après les
bonnes passes c'est comme cela que je
gagne ma vie et combien gagnez-vous cela
dépend des fêtes combien jusqu'à 2500
francs parfait relais
[Applaudissements]
pour cette année c'est le 16 janvier que
la fiesta commencé mais depuis les
origines les choses ont changé la mode
de la tauromachie à l'espagnol a franchi
l'atlantique on a construit à sins et
l'hérault des arènes en béton les a
baptisés le colisée c'est maintenant par
une corrida dans le colisée que la fête
du doux nom de jésus démarre
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
cette année pour l'ouverture il y à
celui que tout le monde veut voir
l roulis 16 ans l'un des plus jeunes
matador de l'histoire la première
tournée en amérique latine pour cet
espagnol
[Musique]
j'ai l'ambition d'aller là où personne
n'est jamais allé
faire ce que personne n'a osé faire dans
la tauromachie
[Musique]
en un an ou liane lopez ce jeune
madrilène est devenu l'attraction la
star on se l'arrachent
[Musique]
son maintien
m
son tarif 70 mille dollars par corrida
400 mille francs pour 40 minutes face à
des taureaux
la tradition c'est dans des champs aux
abords de la ville qu'elle se perpétue
d'autres gradins reconstruit chaque
année pour 6 après midi de folie pour
les six corps alleyras pendant 18 ans la
fête s'était arrêté le 20 janvier 1981
les gradins s'était écroulé personne n'a
jamais su le nombre de morts entre 1000
et 15 cents dit-on l'an dernier la
pression a été trop forte les autorités
ont à nouveau autorisé leur construction
d'un côté hors de la ville les derniers
préparatifs de la fête populaire les
arènes de bois
de l'autre côté on fait la queue devant
le colisée les arènes en béton ici seuls
les riches de la région peuvent venir se
donner des sensations les places sont à
60 francs pour les moins chères 500
francs pour les meilleurs
la corrida d'ouverture avec l roulis
c'est pour 15h30 ce 16 janvier
chaque fois qu'il se prépare dans sa
chambre d'hôtel son père est là
[Musique]
les failles
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il n'y a pas que le doux nom de jésus
que l'on invoque l roulis comme tous les
toreros compte surtout sur la protection
de la vierge de la macarena son valet
d'épée armando aussi
[Musique]
armando accompagne l roulis depuis ses
débuts dans l'arène il y as et enroule
yann avait neuf ans
[Musique]
aujourd'hui je veux triompher comme tous
les jours
comme à chaque fois que je mets mon
habit
en hausse
le haut
[Musique]
dans le colisée tout la bonne société de
signes c'est l'hérault est venu la fête
peut commencer
on
[Applaudissements]
les moments où j'ai le plus peur c'est
que dans certaines positions je ne sais
plus si le taureau peuvent encore nés ou
pas
si oui tant pis pour moi sinon tant
mieux pour le public
tout l'art des grands matadors éditons
de dominer le taureau
il faut jamais perdre le respect du
taureau le jour où tu perds ce respect
c'est toi qui est perdu
[Musique]
suicidaire non c'est un métier où tu
conscience du risque sa vie à chaque
fois
parfois par excès d'ambition on veut
trop bien faire pour convaincre le
public
alors tu t'approches et tu t'approches
le plus près possible du taureau il a
tout peut arriver
[Applaudissements]
dans le monde du taureau une légende
fait son chemin elle roulis ne quitterai
jamais une arène à pied il part soit sur
les épaules de ceux qui le portent en
triomphe soit sur une civière
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
les triumph ou la civière caliman les
connais également il est aussi torero
l'une des gloires de la ville lui n'a
jamais tué un taureau ni même connu les
arènes en béton caliman n'a jamais non
plus mis les pieds dans les hôtels de
luxe
pourtant dans son quartier caliman est
riche le seul à posséder voiture
téléviseur et magnétoscopes
sa plus fervente admiratrice sa femme
c'est elle la trésorière
qui gardent l'argent c'est moi
je le cache dans les chaussettes pour
qu'on ne vole pas
il faut se méfier des voleurs
combien pouvez-vous gagné par chorale
peut gagner miss france 2000 francs
parcourra les rats jusqu'à 5000 francs
quand lass était bonne
c'est parfois c'est pas bon
c'est l'argent des taureaux ma maison ma
voiture tout ce que je possède c'est
grâce à la vierge à dieu et aux taureaux
sur l'écran à longueur de journées
passent et repassent les images des
exploits de caliman devant le poste ses
trois enfants et leurs copains de la rue
[Musique]
on
s'en sort pas mal on vit bien grâce au
taureau
ans
récemment
ma mère disait que les toreros étaient
des sorciers
qui l'on sort cela les femmes alors je
tendais ça qu'il ne fallait pas se
frotter à halle sinon on en tomber
amoureux et
c'est ce qui vous est arrivé
oui grâce à dieu
je l' ai vu la première fois dans une
chorale ra et je suis tombée amoureuse
[Musique]
pourquoi vous faites cela
l'a béni pour me protéger
pour avoir la chance avec moi et que le
spectacle soit beau
ici on se recommandent à la vierge et au
sein
c'est ma protection
moi je suis un artiste de la chorale et
rats sains et grands personnages de
toute la côte nord de colombie
je suis un des meilleurs toreros
pourquoi cette eau de cologne pour la
chance
pour la chance et pour les femmes
mais moi je suis toujours avec ma femme
ne me laisse jamais seul alors je la
respecte
ma femme je l'appelle la cani mana c'est
mon ange gardien elle m'accompagne
partout
ma voiture je les appelais le taureau
bleu car je les ai achetés grâce à
l'argent des taureaux
[Musique]
on aime bien arriver tôt à la chorale ra
pour que ma femme est une bonne place
dans les gradins ensuite je pars
attendre le premier taureau
dans la région de sin celeron envie de
l'élevage les grands propriétaires ans
vit très bien ce sont eux qui
fournissent les taureaux pour la chorale
airs à la fête populaire il en faut
beaucoup 40 par après midi
l'hacienda sans intérêts ça
ici règne donna retour au conflit dont
le plus riche du temps
on
[Applaudissements]
vous de faire mais très grande oui très
grand combien
combien c'était le total
vous le dirais pas
vous avez beaucoup de bétail ça non plus
je le dis pas
[Rires]
sont ils dangereux voto rose
sont nées et ils ont grandi ici les
taureaux de chorales et raon une longue
vie certains deviennent très célèbre lui
ces tueurs à gages et cette année je ne
vais pas le lâcher dans l'arène de synth
et l'hérault il est trop vieux je le
garde comme reproducteurs
l'élevage c'est ma passion
elle vient de mes ancêtres qui était
déjà de grands éleveurs
ma famille a toujours participé aux
faits
j'ai acheté des taureaux espagnols très
cher plusieurs millions de pesos mais
les miens sont bien meilleurs j'ai créé
une ligne et
sont beaux ces taureaux
si les gens de la région disent que les
leurs sont bien plus dangereux que les
taureaux espagnols c'est que ce d'ici ne
sont jamais mises à mort ils connaissent
les jeux de la reine ils ont connu
l'homme ils savent comment cela se passe
lorsqu'ils choisissent une cible il la
rate rarement le plus célèbre d'entre
tous c'était elle bataille
le père de celui ci une chanson lui a
été consacrée
balle aille il a fait trente ou quarante
corrida un taureau assassin un tueur
d'homme et de chevaux
d'âge où il a tué un homme dans un
village autres taureaux avait tué
quelqu'un oui
alors je n'ai envoyé dans la fête d'un
autre village
et le beau frère de l'homme qui avaient
été tuées quinze jours avant a décidé de
se venger en lui plantant des
banderilles empoisonnés
ils avaient plus mon plus beau taureau
comment savez vous qu'elle était
empoisonné
son sang était comme de l'eau
en fait moi je pense qu'il a été touché
à la moelle épinière
pas du tout il a été empoisonnée tgv
[Musique]
m
ban
moi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
caliman est un héros mais le
tout-puissant ici sedona retour
raymond vall is it
[Musique]
le
[Applaudissements]
son surnom caliman emprunté au héros
d'une bande dessinée il est même allé
jusqu'à copier son étrange costume seule
touche personnelle les chaussures de
footballeur pour ne pas glisser sur la
piste je les admire beaucoup
il est très courageux c'est vrai que les
toreros ont beaucoup de courage peu de
gens sont si courageux je suis amoureuse
de lui
elle est à
sur son vêtement le nom de son sponsor
un restaurant de la ville layan air à 21
pour lequel il fait de la publicité en
distribuant également des calendriers
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
15h le 17 janvier les tribunes sont
bondées 7000 personnes
[Musique]
le premier faux va pouvoir être lâché
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]